we have this story
from teamcast.com popular twitch
streamers hassan [ __ ] and vosh banned
from platform for racism against white
people
literally now i'm actually going to um
i've got some criticism for first i've
got criticism for hassan absolutely but
i've got criticism and some defense for
vosh
vosh
i don't think cared at all overtly
stated he was going to say the racial
slur laughed got banned and laughed
again
so my attitude towards vosh is if you
publicly say
these companies are private companies
they can ban whoever they want and if
you use a slur you'll get banned and
then you literally go on the channel
laughing saying you're gonna do it i'm
like yeah you respect it like you're
just trolling you like he knew he was
gonna get banned it's not hypocritical i
just think he shouldn't be saying the
racial slurs and i think he has bad
ideas on you know massive multinational
corporations but i'm not i'm not gonna
say hypocritical for him to be laughing
about it now hassan
is the guy who actually puts out videos
where he says that people on the right
should follow the rules and they just
want to make their own right wing echo
chamber and own the libs but because
they break the rules they get banned
well he literally won his channel and
said that he's allowed to say racial
slurs particularly if they're against
white people and now he's gotten a band
for it the important thing here is
twitch bands are not bands they're like
they'll reinstate you at some point so
they don't call it suspension or
whatever it's the weirdest thing they're
like i got banned for this and then
but they reinstate you tomorrow it's not
really a ban yeah they're going to be
back i think in in a very short time
especially with their uh user base
whatever they have saying hey please get
these people back on this platform but
i still don't understand why people have
to describe other people as salty
delicious
i i don't i don't get it what is that
reference to um oh oh oh oh
delicious
luke's a big fan of cracker barrels his
favorite restaurant i absolutely love
greg
so um anyway i think you know what word
was used and uh no i'm pretty sure on
youtube you're allowed to say cracker
and and karen loud stuff because uh
youtube agrees with hassan in the
context twitch apparently doesn't which
is weird now i will say though i don't
think you can call someone a cracker
what happened was i think hassan
directly said you are an effing ba you
know there you go in general you want to
avoid calling people names yeah on
social media that's that draws the ire
of admins
yeah if it's a nice word if you use it
as a name-calling tactic but here's
here's the craziest thing to me
when it comes to the idea of left or
right in terms of the economic sense
vosh and hassan and and and i normally
don't like to talk about like other you
know internet personalities but this is
relevant towards the conversation of the
commons and these are two of some some
like these are two of the biggest
commentators on the internet hassan i
believe is the biggest in the on the
left how is it that we here at tim cast
irl are to the left of them when it
comes to this particular issue i'm not
going to pretend we're to the left of
him on a bunch of issues relating to
businesses
but
we are to the left or at least in the
lower quadrant towards libertarian yeah
i think when it comes to social media
this is more about authoritarianism and
libertarianism statism versus freed
freedom more so than it is about left
versus right
where i fall
uh relative to hassan and them i don't
know but i think i'm definitely
on the libertarian aspect but this is
the reason why i say we're to the left
even luke is to the left of them on this
issue is that what we're talking about
is private corporate power taking over
the commons twitter facebook youtube etc
have seized the the spaces in which we
communicate and started exerting their
will to force politics in a certain
direction that is not government that is
not state that is private power that has
built up enough of it to seize the
commons
now i'm pretty sure luke you're opposed
to censorship on these platforms
absolutely and especially the collusion
that a lot of these big tech companies
including amazon have what the pentagon
have with the cia and how much they work
hand-in-hand together which makes them
not a private entity but a quasi-state
private entity that of course colludes
together for the personal benefit of the
ruling elites and creates billionaires
that have way too much power way too
much control only because of the
government allowing them to have this so
i wouldn't even argue
yeah absolutely festive i wouldn't even
argue that i'm on the left again the
spectrum is either your status or you
believe in freedom i believe in absolute
freedom stop stop having multinational
corporations colluding with jeff bezos
with amazon with with prime with twitch
and all that it's just too much
government interference too much uh
policy directed in the benefit of them
that's screwing everyone else over
giving an unfair advantage to to regular
competitors to an extent but gab mines
rumble odyssey all these platforms exist
the issue is they have monopoly power
exactly well if you look at a lot of the
infrastructure that facebook that google
that amazon have built they have built
it on us tax paying dollars that of
course incentivized and worked with the
intelligence agencies and a lot of other
people within the pentagon that helped
them have an unfair advantage on
everyone else so when you look at the
collusion that's been happening i would
argue that it is absolutely not a
private enterprise it is an enterprise
that of course has its benefits and just
like it hit people on the right it's
eventually going to hit people on the
left because censorship of course knows
no bounds eventually it has in this
instance but they're going to get their
channel back but later down the line i
think this larger kind of censorship
stick that hit the right predominantly
more than the left is eventually going
to wipe anyone else who has even a
smidget of anti-establishment within
them smidget yeah smidget like a little
smidgen like a smidget smidget that's a
word right i like
i'm curious what your stance is on uh
i i radically err on the side of
individualism and free markets but i do
understand how difficult it is if you're
looking at google which may have a 100
year monopoly on on the search engine
before anyone really you know competes
with them so we're talking about an
issue that could take the course of our
lifetimes to correct so is but what kind
of action do we want to see on that
front do we want our corrupt mitch
mcconnell kevin mccarthy chuck schumer
nancy pelosi coalition do we want them
to deal with it or do we want
individuals to deal with it somehow
and obviously there's no perfect answer
to this because we would have had a
solution already and as as tim said you
know there's rumble there's all these
other
startup sites uh donald trump's getting
in the mix with the social media site
we'll see what happens but i think
google
it uncontested has the biggest monopoly
and they are the biggest threat uh as
opposed to like you know facebook maybe
who knows what kind of staying power
they have twitter they might
self-immolate at this point with their
you know woke ceo and the social justice
warriors that run the site but i think
google has a very serious monopoly they
not only have a monopoly on on the
search but they have a monopoly over our
minds essentially because it's so 99
point whatever percent of the population
still uses google you're getting all of
your results from google google is is
like a state as luke said is basically
like a state enterprise at this point
and it and it's very much a threat to
our civilization for the the the fans of
vash and hassan who may end up watching
this or maybe watching it i'll give you
a very simple explanation for um the
issue with control of the commons
so
would you would you agree
that conservatives
don't want to use preferred pronouns i
think the answer most people regardless
of left or right would say well of
course conservatives don't want to use
someone's preferred pronouns
so on twitter for instance and many
other platforms they enforce the use of
these pronouns
now if you're on the left you may agree
with that i'm not telling you you're not
allowed to feel that way by all means
you can have that opinion okay i respect
you having your right to your opinion
the issue then becomes if that is
clearly and discernibly a left wing
position and the right is at odds with
it the rules on twitter directly and
negatively impact the right and not the
left that is a rule on the platform dead
naming is man
this is
overt now you can say and and what the
left ability says is tim's arguing in
favor of transphobia or whatever i never
said that i'm saying just understand
if you know conservatives say i don't
want to use your pronouns then the rules
favor the left ergo you are in a
left-wing echo chamber where big tech
firms are controlling the narrative and
forcing it in a certain direction now of
course for many on the left they're like
well that's good because they're pushing
my ideas great by all means feel that
way but now don't deny that the rules
are absolutely set up to to be a
negative to be detrimental to the right
probably because the people who run
these companies agree with you on those
opinions well when you've got you know
80 or so million people in this country
who don't agree with that then i think
it's fair to say we have a very serious
problem now you know hassan has done uh
one of the things one of the videos i
watched from him uh recently
was him talking about the right doesn't
want to use conservative platforms
because they want to own the libs
and what they don't understand what
hassan needs to understand is it's not
about owning the libs because obviously
hassan you do content where you own the
cons i mean that's a common thing
regardless of your political faction
it's the issue that twitter owns the
commons they own it their parlor doesn't
have nearly enough people to even talk
to to debate to question to to engage
with the same is true for rumble the
same is true for minds these are these
are platforms you know good for them
getter i mean it's great they exist but
people want to be in the commons they
want to walk up to their neighbor and
say i humbly disagree and some of them
want to screech well we don't like it
when people screech but how are you even
supposed to debate the idea of
misgendering if you get banned before
you can even say it so imagine if you
went to the town square and the mayor
was using the police force to beat you
and kick you out because you said black
lives matter and that happens too and
it's wrong
the rules are absolutely slanted and
that's a problem
yeah we're also being ruled by
algorithms algorithms that can't really
figure out discernment so whenever you
say something that's on google's no talk
list they will hit you no matter what
the context and a lot of individuals do
get hit especially smaller channels
smaller individuals with less
subscribers who of course are trying to
legitimately talk about an issue but
because of of youtube stigmatization
they can't there's so many history
channels on youtube that got nuked that
got utterly destroyed for simply just
talking about history and a perspective
that is important to understand but you
can't on youtube because of the
algorithm because of ai deciding if
you're going to have a voice in our
current society and that to me is
absolutely ridiculous and when the left
was celebrating this kind of political
censorship cheering it on i said it's
only a matter of time until they get you
i think we're reaching that kind of
major bridge that it's affecting them
and i think it's only going to affect
them more just like antifa they use
antifa the state knows everything that
antifa does they know all the
individuals are part of their
institutions the intelligence agencies
have a database of all their names
they're going to use them but after
they're they're done taking out the
people on the right that's the next
people that are going to go after let me
just stress
when it comes to the january 6 committee
they just got the text messages from how
many people members of congress
mainstream media donald trump jr
journalists
they just went to the phone companies
and said we'd like their their private
communications and they went you got it
boss and then they released it to the
public amazing now
somebody chatted us
have we ever had michael malus and vosh
on at the same time
that sounds like a good idea yeah it
does i don't know if you guys vasha or
michael you'd want to be down for
something like that but you know i was
like i don't want to keep just having
the same people on but that actually
does sound like a fun show
yeah i wonder
you know because because michael's just
like overtly anarchist and vashta is a
libertarian socialist so i think they'd
be really interesting conversation there
that'd be fun well you heard it here
we'll we'll reach out and see what
people are up to thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time